good morning everyone um welcome uh to
Yale for the closing Workshop of the
understanding the nature of inference
project I am Priya natarajan an
astrophysicist jointly appointed in the
Departments of astronomy and physics at
Yale where I also serve as the current
director of Yale's Flagship
interdisciplinary Frankie program in
science in the humanities
as you are all probably aware this is an
intellectual
experiment although David Kaiser just
reminded me the likes of him and me
should not be left to do well near any
experimental
equipment but um real material
equipment um so this is an experiment in
crossing boundaries real and imagined
amongst intellectual disciplines that
are often unfortunately siloed and do
not speak to each other and it's an
experiment in learning new languages and
metaphors as well as new ways of
thinking probing and understanding a
really complex World it has probably not
escaped you all that even the terms
causal and inference to say nothing of
causal inference means something
completely different in each of our
disciplines at Yale we decided to take
on this Challenge and explore how we
could talk and have an fruitful exchange
of ideas that disrupt tired old ways of
thinking and open up new arenas for
interdisciplinary engagement so here we
are so our project thus far has focused
on deeply examining the process of
inference of cause and effect across
disciplines and our motivation has been
to understand this process using various
kinds of evidence and data conceptual
modeling and simulations as proxies for
control old scientific
experiments at this Workshop we have
assembled an extraordinary group of
Scholars experts across different
intellectual Fields ranging from
epidemiology anthropology cosmology
genetics computer science mathematics to
name a few as well as philosophers of
science who study the nature of
inference and causal relationships we
look forward to exploring the various
kinds of conceptual Frameworks used to
distill the role that modeling plays in
aiding the disentangling of correlation
and causation which is one of the
fundamental open questions in
epistemology today uh this distinction
between causation and correlation
particularly Amplified in the data of
big era AI machine learning and so on so
the production of new knowledge is
inevitably linked to the understanding
of cause and effect and the underlying
principles if any exists that is that
map between them and the study of
causality lies at the very core of all
scientific inquiry sifting out causality
is also imperative when predictions for
future behavior of complex systems under
investigation or sought there are many
approaches to studying causation which
we will get a glimpse of in the next two
days including probabilistic
manipulative counterfactual and
structural ones that invariably comprise
a set of tools very powerful tools that
will help us discriminate between causal
connection
and mere statistical associations our
multidisiplinary project thus far has
included a colloquium and a post
colloquium discussion series and this
Workshop is a culmination of various
themes that we have engaged with over
the course of the last two and a half
years our work is supported by the
Frankie program uh in science and the
humanities at Yale the Kemp fund at Yale
and the John Templeton Foundation I
would like to uh thank our entire court
team uh Dr Tai Camp the executive
director of the Frankie program for
guiding all our activities thus far and
helping us shape this two-day workshop I
want to give a special shout out to
Larry gladney our dean of science who is
here in the audience thank you so much
Larry for uh coming and I want to thank
all our invited speakers some of whom
have traveled far to be here and for
generously sharing their ideas uh being
open to sharing ideas with AC cross
discipline AR audience and pretty much
you know say thank you to everyone in
the audience for participating in this
interdisciplinary Adventure I'm really
excited and look forward to learning
from everyone over the next two days and
without further Ado let's get started
our first session is themed around
causation and our opening speaker um is
Samantha kleinberg and her talk is
titled learning causes and using them
thank you Samantha and the floor is
[Applause]
yours thanks so much for having me
whoops wrong microphone um so I started
getting interested in causality when I
was a PhD student in 2006 and I was
reading a lot of biology papers but
there were something sort of weird about
them all these papers had causality in
the title and the abstract and then
there was not really any discussion of
causality during the paper um or
causality would be you know coming up in
the discussion and throughout the paper
there'd be associations and so sort of
wondering where did the causality happen
what do people mean by
causes um recently I went back and found
a bunch of papers that confirmed this
anecdote um n 84% of these studies that
one group looked at that were just
predictions and associations mentioned
causality
somewhere another one looked at where
the causality happened um there's a sort
of switching back and forth between
causal language and non-causal language
uh another one looked at this is my
favorite uh 31% that didn't really
actually have any causality used
misleading language but then also in
their discussion disavowed the causality
and so they were sort of selling the
causality and the title in the abstract
but then saying actually we don't really
have any causal relationships um so it's
interesting that causality kept coming
up a lot but also there was a sort of
shady do we have causes do we don't does
it matter um at the same time people are
also saying things like this that
actually you don't need causes right you
know and this was a nice quote telling
the best story about the research
findings you don't need to say that X
causes Y and this is for epidemiological
research um and the authors agree we
want to prevent disease want to
intervene apparently causes are not
super helpful for that um and also that
we actually can't even find causes we
can't definitively claim causality and
so that seemed really bad um given all
the papers talking about causality and
claiming toine
causes as a computer scientist uh this
came up a lot uh people saying don't
worry about it right if you're trying to
make predictions who cares why they work
you only need to know that your
prediction does work um and so maybe you
know just give up on this
Pursuit um but to me it was more like
this you know if causality isn't so
important why is everyone claiming we
have cause or relationships or trying to
find cause or relationships one might be
everyone else is doing it and so if
everyone else is mentioning cause or
relationships maybe we should too um or
there's some value in in cause of
relationships right the same reason
people lie on dating profiles right you
lie about things that you think other
people care about uh or that might make
you more appealing or make your research
more appealing right and I think it's
kind of the second one that there is
some value in mentioning causes and
that's why people talk about them and
maybe exaggerate their findings so I was
a computer scientist I guess I'm still
sort of a computer scientist um at the
time because computational biology
rejected me so my PhD was computer
science and so I thought okay what do
computer scientists have have to say
about causality and this is what that
looked like and so this was causality in
computer science in 2006 was Bas Nets
and they were generally very simple it
was you know you have two variables how
do we find causal relationships between
them um wasn't super satisfying for me
because I was interested in problems
that looked like this uh this is an
actual patient in the neuro IU at
Colombia where I've collaborated with
people since
2010 um it's a super complex environment
there's lots of things measured um this
is an ICU that actually stores all this
data um other icus don't and so you just
happen to see things streaming by in
real time maybe a nurse writes down some
of the variables numbers maybe they
don't um I work with other IUS where
records are still kept on paper and
scanned in as
PDFs and so this is actually you know
Cutting Edge uh but it's a really
complex decision-making problem and
there's this tension between this is
what reality looks like for this problem
and then we have our our baset with our
our two two variables um and no timing
or complexity or you know interactions
between these
variables um but talking to the doctors
it did seem they did want causes they
wouldn't they weren't going to be
satisfied with predictions and just
knowing you know this is what's uh going
to happen to the patient um I also work
on decision-making problems where
patients are making choices like in
diabetes um it's not the doctor helping
you manage your blood glucose every day
it's you as an individual having to do
that um and again people don't don't
just want predictions and so I was
satisfied that yes they actually do want
causal relationships um they don't want
to know there's been a huge history of
alarms and icus and usually that's what
the computer scientists come along and
provide um there's alarms lots of bad
things happen in ICU can't do anything
about a lot of them um and so the
doctors nurses get alarm fatigue and
start ignoring the alarms and then what
ultimately happens is they ignore ones
that they should have listened to and in
bad cases patients have died as a result
um because most the alarms are not
actionable and we're not actually
providing causal information why is this
happening and most importantly what can
we do about what's happening um
nevertheless uh some computer scientists
have actually doubled down not only do
we not need causes we don't actually
really need doctors either um so this is
my my favorite uh from Jeff Hinton in
2016 um saying you know what just stop
training Radiologists it's just
completely obvious in five years deep
learning is going to be able to do
better uh it's going to get more
experience and then he sort of walked
back and said well okay if you're like a
radiologist you're like the coyote who's
looked over the edge of the cliff but
hasn't looked down and doesn't know
there's no ground under him um he
acknowledged maybe we need some
Radiologists but we have enough already
we don't need to train
more and so uh you know I don't think
any of us want uh computers giving us
diagnosis uh but even so this idea that
learning from data and experience is all
you need we've actually seen that's
totally wrong right um and so there have
been lots of cases of radiology has been
a really popular application area for
deep learning and there's nice really
quick uh cycle of hype and then uh the
antidote to the hype of as we learn deep
learning is better than radiologist and
then a week later actually no it's not
um so this is an example of one of those
papers where uh it's trying to predict
pneumonia um and then the numbers on the
left they're showing how important these
different areas of the X-ray are um and
then a sort of weird one is in the upper
left you see there's a one next to
Portable because the algorithm thinks
it's really important that Ed a portable
scanner uh and that's going to help me
predict whether this patient has
pneumonia or not and so it's using
features that are totally inappropriate
not useful at all have nothing to do
with the patient's diagnosis or not um
and that was a mistake that a
radiologist would absolutely never make
right a radiologist is not going to look
that information at all uh because they
understand which things are actually
meaningful for for the disease or
not uh another fun case was Google flu
um so Google was using people's Search
keywords to predict cases of the flu um
track cases of the flu over time and
they were doing it actually better than
the CDC for a while um so people got
very excited you can figure out how much
flu is in the area based on you know
searching for symptoms and treatments
and things like that um and then what
happened afterwards was suddenly Google
is predicting twice as many cases of the
flu as there actually were um and then
now we know more about Google flu as a
failure um my favorite thing about this
is the quote I showed you about
prediction and not needing to know how
things work um was from a Google
employee after this actually happened
and so I don't think Google's fully
learned the lesson there that even if
you want predictions you're not going to
have a robust prediction without cause
of relationships you're not going to be
able to predict when your prediction is
going to stop working we have no idea
why Search keywords relate to cases of
the flu you search based on you your
friends maybe you've heard about Google
doing this and so you search also that
changes your behavior we have no idea
and so even just for prediction which
has been the thing that most computer
scientists try to sell you on uh without
causal relationships uh we need
causes uh second thing we really care
about is explanation I love time series
data so this is my favorite website it
pulls lots of Time series off the web
and then puts them together uh so if you
have any two non-stationary time series
they're non-stationary in similar ways
you can get these really strong
correlations a lot of them involve
cheese for some unknown
reason actually I gave a talk and showed
this and one person was like no I think
this is actually is causal they're
eating too much cheese and then they're
you know falling asleep and then they're
actually dying suffocating because of
all the cheese
consumption and so that that was
enjoyable um but we can make these
stories right I have another one any two
exponential time series look really
similar Starbucks stores and autism
cases follow the same Trend I could also
say use of cell phones and autism cases
probably follow a similar Trend right
there's nothing causal there but because
these have a similar trajectory you can
make a story uh but we don't fully
understand them unless we understand oh
these are just you know the cause here
is time and they're changing in similar
ways over
time um control is probably the most
useful and interesting thing um
sometimes it's linked with explanation
uh this was a case where used simulation
to understand um causes of singular
events and so the Bold line shows a
person glucose over time um the two
Rises the first one is after um a run
and then the later one is after lunch uh
but we can go back and ask questions
what happened if the person didn't have
didn't go for a run or didn't have lunch
or had a smaller lunch it's really hard
if you imagine just the Bold line and
you're a person with diabetes looking at
that figuring out why is my glucose too
low right now right to figure out from
those two events you can't really pick
it apart and say you know was it too
much insulin was it my run was too long
or too intense you don't know uh but we
can go back with simulation and say
actually in this case it turned out it
was the two events together each one
individually would have led to glucose
that was too low it was only the
combination of the two events and so now
once you have that information in the
future you know this is how I should
change my insulin or change my activity
or change my lunch right to avoid
hypoglycemia and so you're much more
able to react to the world once you have
that information about causes um so
spent a lot of time arguing we need
cause relationships causes are really
important if you want to do anything
useful in the world um wrote a couple
books about that and then the last few
years I've also come to believe causes
are necessary uh but
insufficient uh and so the last part of
this talk will be about that
insufficient part um and why we need
understanding of human
behavior so first I wanted to show a few
examples of learning from observation
and so I like to make things difficult I
like really hard cases where we can only
observe I have no ability to experiment
whatsoever um I can't even change what
what gets observed um and can we find
some cause relationships and so the
reason it's interesting is um I was in
bioinformatics as a PhD student and then
HRS came about and were becoming much
more popular and I thought oh this is
really cool we can go back we have 20
years of data on people and see what
happened before they became sick um you
learn very quickly that you don't have
20 years of data on everyone and the
number of people is much smaller and
there's lots of complexity um but for a
person really interested in Time series
it was very exciting time series data
I'll talk about a couple other other
similar
cases um I won't talk as much about the
technical detail but to you know have in
your head what do I mean when I say
cause or relationships it's not a basing
Network a graphical model um I'm my
focus is time I think time is critical
for intervening in the world I think we
care a lot about the timing of the
relationships we find if you take a
medication you really care is this going
to you know Rel my headache in 15
minutes or 4 hours uh if I just tell you
it's going to help you you're probably
not going to be that satisfied with that
um and a lot of relationships are
complicated you have you know
combinations of factors interactions you
have one thing happening until something
else happens um and so to me the natural
way to represent a cause a relationship
is with temporal logic um so that's what
the top the top thing is saying that
vigorous exercise leads to hyperglycemia
in 15 to 40 minutes and this happens
with probability point4 um and so that's
that's for me what a cause relationship
looks like it has timing there might be
other stuff on the left side it could be
multiple factors um maybe the variables
are continuous that's fine they don't
have to be discreet um and there's
always a Time window associated with
that and I also want to discover that
from the data I assume I assume that I
know nothing going in um and how do I
find cause of relationships um and so
basically we're thinking about what
we're doing in the data is what we'd
want to do if we could experiment is
imagine toggling the cause on and off
and seeing how the effect changes and so
that's essentially what we're doing is
keeping everything else fixed and then
holding the cause changing the cause uh
whether it's true or false or its value
and seeing what happens to the effect
there's some other details in there but
that's the basic idea um and again
there's no basing networks and anything
that looks like a basing Network later
on is not a basing
Network just can't can't be uh feed
enough about that sometimes people think
they're basy networks and they get
really uncomfortable because they're
cycles and so I just want to make sure
you're not uncomfortable um so the first
example is uh learning from HR data um
so this was a really poor choice of
problem uh I decided to work on
congestive heart failure and the reason
it's a difficult choice of problem or
poor choice of problem is that it's
really hard from an EHR to know who has
heart failure heart failure is not like
a stroke where you have this acute
dramatic event you know in our data we
can say roughly the time the stroke
happened um it doesn't even make sense
to say when the heart failure happen
right heart failure is a chronic
progressive disease you have the
worsening over time there's not this key
onset time and then it gets worse in the
background until at some point it's
clinically apparent and gets diagnosed
and so really there's like you know a
probability of heart failure over time
and then at some point it becomes you
know discernible um there's not you know
a single piece of evidence in the record
that tells you if a person has heart
failure you can look at diagnosis codes
you can look at medications you can look
at symptoms uh after you do that you see
there's a lot of people who seem to have
symptoms but aren't being treated or
seem to have treatments but no diagnosis
of heart failure um it becomes very
messy and so we did that uh we found
some ways to figure out who had hard
failure who didn't um this was data for
about 30,000 people um in rural
Pennsylvania at Ginger uh we applied our
methods we learned timings from the data
this is what we find um DX means
diagnosis and uh again the the effect
here is not actually heart failure right
because we don't know we have no idea
when heart failure happens um the effect
is the diagnosis of heart failure and
what we're finding is these other things
that are known hypothyroidism diabetes
being overweight they're happening maybe
a year and a half to two years before
the
diagnosis um then it becomes really hard
to interpret you need a lot of
background knowledge so blood pressure
is a notoriously noisy measurement in
the electronic health record we don't
find high blood pressure we find being
on a medication for high blood pressure
because that's less noisy and it's a
much better indicator of whether you
have high blood pressure the same thing
urinary symptoms um that's a symptom of
heart failure frequent night time
urination um and that's what we find is
the most common code here and so what
happens is we're finding people it's not
that the symptom is causing heart
failure that'd be crazy uh the symptom
is happening about uh 8 to 11 months
before the diagnosis of heart failure
but it's really hard if someone just
gives you the data you would have no way
to interpret this and know it's
happening we repeated this uh with data
from Columbia which was much Messier it
was mostly text Data it's really hard to
get time from text Data um and so we
find a lot of things with medications
because the medications were stored in a
structured way and it's much easier to
find uh the person's taking insulin
versus they were diagnosed with diabetes
and so instead of finding the diabetes
or thyroid problems we find the
medications for those
diseases um so there were some successes
there um I moved on I thought well this
was hard because we don't really know
what's happening in between the times
you see a doctor but you have you know a
couple visits a year maybe um and then
what's happening when you're at home
home uh chronic diseases are interesting
because one the main things are
happening outside the hospital if you
have diabetes your doctor is not there
with you every time you have a meal or
exercise saying here's how much insulin
you should take to adjust for that right
you have to figure that out and you're
making decisions all day long about that
um also the data we have is not you know
research grade sensors it's things in
the real world um that become a lot more
uncertain so just give a sense of that
uncertainty um key measurement for
people with diabetes is glucose to blood
glucose which test with a finger stick
or now there are sensors that can
measure glucose sort of continuously uh
get measurement every five minutes so
but they're called continuous um however
the standards for these devices are
pretty LX uh so if you have a value of
uh 150 maybe it's low maybe it's high we
don't really know um hypo hypoglycemia
so glucose that's too low uh can be
really dangerous if your coose is 70
that's pretty Norm that's low end of
normal um but we don't know based on the
error rates could be 60 could be 81 and
that's according to the FDA standards uh
Studies have shown that a lot of devices
don't actually meet those standards um
so it's a really challenging problem for
causal inference if you want to think
how do I find causes of hypo or
hyperglycemia I can't actually trust my
measurements you know if your value is
69 probably it's okay I don't really
know um so I had a small data set where
we really couldn't couldn't throw away
any data and say we're only going to
take the values we're really certain
about um so we incorporated uncertainty
into our C inference and everything here
is based on uh uh it's data driven we're
calculating probabilities in a frequency
based Manner and so I can just wait my
inferences right so I can learn from
some values more strongly than others uh
and this is what the data looked like we
had only 17 people over three days so
pretty small data um there were a lot of
different sensors they were very active
they went rock climbing did all kinds of
other stuff in their daily life uh
sensors broke that's what happens um and
we want to find what are the causes of
hyper hypoglycemia and it was only when
we incorporate the uncertainty that we
could find anything if we didn't do that
we basically found if your glucose is
high it stays high if it's low it stays
low it's true but not very interesting
as a cause of relationship um but once
we incorporated you know what's the
probability that your glucose is high or
low given this value that I've measured
now we can actually make this finding um
that intense activity does lead to high
glucose in 5 to 30 minutes um so that's
exciting but this data set was missing
one of the most important things for
understanding glucose uh which is meals
we didn't know anything about that uh
they were not recorded or rather they
were recorded but uh not timestamped and
so essentially not recorded you can't
use it if you don't know the timing um
one of the challenges and causal
inference has been often we assume we
get data we apply our methods to it we
get some output um but that means we're
starting from scratch with every data
set right which is not really realistic
we kind of we hopefully learn some
things over time um we know some things
about meals and glucose it's actually
really complicated we don't know
everything fat protein all these things
affect your glucose and interact with
carbohydrates um but we thought we can
incorporate some simple information and
so here we use knowledge of the effect
of meals on glucose um we use that to
reconstruct these meals uh uh we won't
talk about that the details but the key
idea is using that we actually know
something and then importantly uh we
develop ways of figuring out what our
knowledge doesn't apply because you
might learn something from one
experiment and it doesn't apply at all
to another population um and there we
could actually find these other
relationships now we found oh moderate
exercise has a different effect than
intense exercise um we found that
actually exercise causes people to have
a meal afterwards which makes sense if
your glucose is going to be low after
moderate exercise you're going to
compensate with a meal um and then other
methods didn't didn't find anything I
could have a whole separate talk about
uh other methods that didn't work at all
in real data but we won't do that today
um and so the the key has been it's
really hard to find cause relationships
in these data um but it's possible with
with some
creativity third application I wanted to
mention um is looking at stroke data so
this is really different in terms of
frequency compared to the other data
sets so in the hospital data data for
30,000 people um is about the same size
as data for 100 stroke patients just
you're talking about dis size so these
are about 100 really intensively
monitored people this is the um
situation you saw in the picture of the
ICU patient Those sensors are measuring
every 1 to 5 Seconds the entire time
someone's in the ICU uh the measurements
depend on the patient status of course
and of no ability to change that um we
have EEG on the surface of the brain EEG
within the brain micro alysis
physiologic
measurements um but A lot's missing and
so this is three patients um x-axis is
time and the y- axis are different
variables which are different for the
different patients um the top person you
can see as during their ICU stay there's
just more variables over time right as
their status changes the doctors think
other things are important and maybe we
should measure them the middle person uh
this is a variable that's measured every
hour uh by a human writing down the
value and you can see these aren't
evenly spaced right because it's an ICU
it's a complex environment lots of
things are happening and it's not
anyone's priority to write down this
number exactly every hour on the hour
right it's not going to happen um last
one there's huge chunks of time with all
variables missing because maybe there's
a surgery or a procedure everything's
disconnected for that other times things
just slip out of where they were and so
if you think of this in terms of causal
inference um none of this missing data
is missing at random right it's all
missing for reason uh which is generally
the patient's health status uh or things
that are happening to the patient or
about the patient and so if we ignore
that then we have a huge problem with
confounding right um and so we spent uh
five years dealing with missing data
problems how do we reconstruct missing
values when you have all variables
missing at a time Point um when the
relationships are lagged between the the
variables uh we develop methods for for
all of those things um so we started
working with this data in 201
201 um by 2015 we actually got a causal
causal model that we believed in um so
this is part of the model um and again
not a basing network uh so the Cycles
are fine um I just don't know how to
represent temporal relationships in a
satisfying way and so there's no time on
the graph but there's time everywhere
and some of these relationships could be
positive some could be negative I'm not
showing you any of that um and the
doctors thought there was this important
transition at 96 hours so we just
crudely separated the data in these two
time periods did our causal inference
for the first period and then for the
second period and we compared them um
and the things to note is one there's
just more cause relationships over time
uh which was interesting um and the
thing that doctors cared about a lot was
this tww perc to the bottom which
represents brain swelling and so if your
causes are changing over time it starts
off with brain temperature later on it's
brain oxygenation blood flow in the
brain um maybe your in iions also have
to be different over time right if your
causes change over time um so that was
super exciting oh and the numbers are
relate to the number of people that
relationship was found in because people
have different things
measured however um this is what the
entire model looked like for me this was
5 years of work I was so excited uh
after this this was like we actually did
it uh We've solved stroke um obviously
and gave this to the doctor you're going
to use this to treat your patients now
right I've solved all your problems and
he called this an Unholy mess um he's
German and very blunt and I thought okay
that's not not exactly what I was hoping
to hear uh we spent like 3 hours going
through this he had a lot of questions
why is this not there well it had no
variation if there's no variation we
can't find CA relationships um and you
know why is this there why is that that
not there um and then his questions were
okay if heart rate causes this what
happens if I give this medication I have
no idea medication's on a variable in
the graph and so I can't tell you
anything about it um right which is the
the key problem is everything here is
you know the variables we measure um his
questions are what ifs about
interventions right and none of the
interventions are on a variable and that
like du calculus you know turning a
variable on and off they're all I have a
strategy where I could maybe change
temperature or you know change blood
flow um but I don't have direct access
to that variable and I couldn't help him
at all uh so then after uh five
years yeah uh this was my my feeling
about that um was maybe I'm the problem
right um i' been telling everyone cause
relationships are super important we
need cause relationships to do anything
if you're going to make decisions or
interventions or predictions you need
causes and then it turns out my
collaborator who you know literally has
his fingers in people's brains couldn't
use these models um so starting in about
2017 I wondered does this actually help
people make
decisions and if we look at how we
evaluate our CA and models we don't
evaluate decision- making of course uh
or computer scientists we evaluate
accuracy and more is better pretty much
uh there's different you know different
metrics but they're all kind of the same
thing and they have the same Val shared
values and the value is did you find
more of the causes that are there and
did you find fewer wrong causes and
maybe sometimes we care about how fast
your algorithm runs or how much data it
needs uh but those are kind of secondary
it's really more is better find me the
most complete model you can possibly
find so I thought okay psychologist
knows things about people um they've
done a lot of work on causality this is
kind of what it looks like reminds me a
little bit of the basy networks that I
found as a PhD student um they're these
very constrainted setups right they're
trying to do controlled studies and
figure out what can people do
interventions to learn cause
relationships in what cases right when
can they infer causes and so there all
these B detectors where you put blocks
on a box and see if it makes music um or
there's like madeup uh microorganisms my
favorite is mind reading aliens uh
probably you have no experience with
mind reading aliens so you have to rely
totally on what the researchers tell you
right you're not combining this at all
with your past knowledge which is really
different from what happened with my
collaborator right he's not looking just
at what I told him he's thinking yeah
but I have this hypothesis about this
relationship why isn't that there or
what is this other one how does that fit
into what I know and that's what happens
when we get guidance about health and
finance and all these other things right
we're not just taking you know this
information about a vaccine in in a
vacuum we're fitting it in with our
beliefs about the disease vaccines in
general all this other stuff so I
started doing decision-making studies uh
where people made everyday choices and
they were um a little bit more realistic
so this was the first one that we did um
we had a student they have uh they just
started college they're adjusting to a
busy schedule um she's trying to avoid
gaining weight but also wants to make
friends and uh leave time for homework
and studying and so we showed people CM
model or the same model as just text um
or no caal model and to this point I was
still optimistic um I thought this is
like taking an open book exam if I give
you the CM model even if you already
know the information you know it's like
it's reminding you right of what you
already know um and that's not it all
what happened and so we found CA models
made things worse um people consistently
made worse choices and it didn't matter
if it was a diagram or text uh people
made worst choices with the CM model um
so that was really disappointing after
my years spent uh trying to find CAA
models from really really difficult data
and also convincing people that CAA
models are really important and useful
um and we looked at everything we looked
at you know how much time do people
spend on it were they ignoring it no
they spent longer with it um we did
again maybe about four years of
interventions of what if we show people
how little they know if we give them
like quizzes or help them reflect on
their knowledge maybe they'll be more
open to new information because they'll
realize they actually need the
information didn't work at all people
people knew that they didn't know
anything uh they tried to use the model
and they couldn't and in all these cases
people were also doing these questions
about aliens and robots and things like
that and they had no problem in those
cases right they were totally fine when
the question was about robots but once
it was about you know saving for
retirement or managing their diabetes
suddenly they were doing terribly on
these questions and also they were
losing confidence as well and so we
measured um how they felt about their
decisions and they felt worse about
their choices with the caal model um so
it was really quite bad and so my mental
model of how things were going to go was
this at the start I was like you know
you have this Gap in your knowledge I'm
coming in with my c a model I'm going to
slot it right into that Gap and you know
problem solved um and I think it was
more like this that you know you already
have all these beliefs I'm giving you
information it does not fit cleanly into
these other things and I haven't helped
you figure out how to map it to to what
you already know um and so skipping
ahead a few years finally we have some
POS positive results uh so we'll we'll
end on a good note um what if we focus
people's attention and so it wasn't
people's willingness to use the CM model
it wasn't that they didn't understand
what a caal model means they understood
that perfectly well um we think that it
was that they didn't really know which
parts of it to use or how how to combine
it with their existing knowledge and so
we started doing studies uh testing that
um so using either very complex model um
or giving people just the parts that
were relevant and so in this case if you
think back to the diagram I showed you
before you could use that for lots of
different questions and that's what we
often try to create right it's a general
model you could use it for many
different purposes um we don't
specifically tailor it to this is one
decision that you're going to make
here's the right model for that decision
um but what if we did right and so here
we're showing people different parts of
the model depending on the question that
they're answering um and so that's why
there there are different models here
and some of them have Cycles here the
dashed edges are um negative cause
relation ships um because it was based
on a well-known uh diagram about obesity
that use that similar format uh that was
a very complex model but I w't show you
that one questions looked very similar
um again we have a person they have some
constraints um this one they don't have
that much time uh they're concerned
about their weight and they have a few
options and again the options aren't
variables right it's not you know
increase carbohydrates or increase
exercise it's what exact strategy you're
going to do which is much harder and
much much more different right so he
could do nothing he could fast forward
through commercials he could get takeout
or change up his recipes a little bit uh
so finally we had some positive results
um turns out there was no difference
between the simple and uh the complex
diagram and no information uh but
Simplicity that that turned out to be
the answer giving people just the
information they needed putting blinders
on them uh led to better
results the interesting thing is you can
also use that uh to change people's
preferences in maybe uh undesirable ways
and so it's known that people prefer
intervening on root nodes um compared to
internal or direct causes and so we
tested that with this causal chain um
seems a bit you know more sensible or if
you're you have a probalistic model uh
it's mathematically Superior to
intervene on the direct cause right uh
so you'd think why not directly change
someone's diet um versus like not watch
as much TV so you're not exposed to Food
ads and then have an unhealth diet
because of the food ads that's sort of
indirect and could fail at different
points um but when we show people this
model then in this in the simple model
they picked the food ads more and so you
do have to be careful how you simplify
the
model uh but we expanded Beyond Health
we tried lots of different decision-
making uh so picking a college um
lowering your carbon footprint mental
health all these different cases um and
the exciting news was we found the exact
same thing in every domain uh simple
models helped um we showed if you just
highlight the relevant path so make it
orange draw attention to it that works
so you don't have to just you know hide
the whole model but you have to show
people uh what part of the model is uh
so I started wondering you know is there
some level of complexity that's right
you know maybe there's something in
between these like really big models and
really small one um and tested what if
we just add in a little bit of extra
couple extra nodes couple extra edges um
no that was not helpful at all um and
the results were basically the same as
if you give people a completely
complicated model and so any extra
information gives you an opportunity to
overthink basically um and if you think
of like when you give your students
exams and they have questions during the
test about a question that you think was
maybe very easy um they're overthinking
right I have these questions uh I gave
an exam last spring and the easiest
possible question people had the most
questions about for me during the exam
and they're like well what about this or
should I you know like rely on my
knowledge of calculus and all that like
I'm like no really is just take it at
face value it's as simple as you think
it is um and you know as you know more
you have more opportunity to to
overthink right and so leaving any
possibility for that people start and
we've done other studies where people
describe their decision-making process
and they add in so much extra stuff
that's not in the model they talk about
you know their preferences about
medications it's really hard to take
medications maybe they should start with
this you know if they develop a routine
and they get a dog and they walk the dog
then this will happen um and then
that'll that'll solve their blood
pressure right um and so that's why you
don't have the opportunity to do that
when the questions about aliens and
robots right there's no potential for
like coming up with these really
convoluted
stories still you might think like you
know you have a PhD probably uh you know
yourself you like getting a lot of
information you would do better than
people in the studies if I just let you
choose how much information you want um
and so we tested that right instead of
randomizing people let them choose and
let them choose for each question and so
they would see here's what all these
types of information look like um and
your next question is going to be about
retirement or finances how much
information do you
want um so a good fraction of people
picked the simple diagram which is the
best choice so that was good news um
however people don't know how much
information they need and people who
think they need the most complicated
information or no information at all are
not right uh those numbers are almost
exactly the same as when we randomize
people um and simple diagrams again were
still had the highest accuracy um and
then we had other data that uh was fun
it turned out that women did better in
all information conditions than men um
also people with less education did
better uh again with the overthinking uh
the more you know the more opportunity
you have to like come up with all these
extra things all these extra ideas add
information that's just not relevant and
and not useful at all to the to the
diagram um but again we were excited
that after again about five years
finally we made CA of models better than
nothing uh which was really depressing
for for giving talks was just and the
why for a while it was we can make CA
models as good as nothing uh but not
better so this was a nice
Improvement um but going back to the
beginning um so I've changed my my tune
a little bit that um completeness is not
the right thing to value in caal models
right it might be helpful for you know
scientific accuracy and understanding
but if we really care about
decision-making or interventions um
that's not that's not what we need right
and so we need new ways of thinking
about what is utility for a CM model um
here we didn't take into account
people's decision context how much time
they have what their background is uh we
didn't do any of that and so there's a
lot of other other stuff to be explored
there um also uh other things I didn't
mention uh fund Dirty Laundry um I I
didn't tell you how I find variables I
don't know what a variable is I have no
idea how to tell you what the right
variables are for your problem uh but
everything they're really important uh
and all guarantees are relative to
having the right variables and so get it
right um are assumptions are almost
never true um you know and so we can't
guarantee that anything is causal
because all the assumptions we need to
make are false I also have no idea how
much data I need um you know there's no
power analysis whatsoever more is
probably better uh but we don't know
it's you know I can sometimes tell you
after the fact that I didn't have enough
data um but I can't tell you proactively
here's how much you need to collect to
find a caal model um and so there's huge
gaps in in finding causal models from
data uh even though I've shown you some
success stories and so I'll and there um
and just thank their all the different
collaborators that were involved in this
work
[Applause]
thanks thank you so much for giving us
the unvarnished truth about Cal modeling
so um I just want to invite anyone who
wants to speak to just press the button
on the microphone and um speak up um I
I'm happy to start with the first
question so um
I was really curious how are you so in
this in the process of making those uh
causal chains are you marginalizing over
prior information that people
have or is prior information is that
really not part of the whole scheme we
we haven't Incorporated like individuals
prior knowledge we don't know we've done
other studies trying to just quantify
someone's degree of knowledge about a
problem um but haven't used that we
haven't made predictions for example
about like what would someone um choose
we've done other work looking at where
we got people's mental models uh another
fun project is how do you know you got
someone's mental model accurately um how
do you evaluate mental models that's
been been fun um but mostly what we
found there was we couldn't change
people's mental models they had the same
mental model before and before and after
yeah um David then Shan and
then uh just very briefly that was
really fascinating um lots of questions
for for the for the last main part um of
the presentation where simple models
were better all around right that's what
I took at least the message to be can
you say a bit more um it's if I if I
follow correctly your team was trying to
at least in some of these instan trying
to build a a more complete model and
then work from there to simplify or am I
missing am I forgetting working to uh on
all the Health Data the goal was find
all the ca relationships in the data um
in the simple models casee we started
with models that were in the literature
on on all these different topics and
then simplified them for these different
decisions so I so my question really is
what were there rules or strategies or
rules of thumb in how your team made the
simplification I can imagine simplifying
in all kinds of ways and some
simplifications might actually be less
helpful than than others if there's a
complete a more complete model available
what's the decision tree to say this is
the simple model I'll now put in front
of my people and this will be more
helpful or less helpful for what they
need to do do that's a great question um
for this the simplification was very
simple the simplification was literally
just showing the paths in the model that
were relevant for that decision and so
we showed if we know for everything here
there was a right answer um essentially
which is another topic people sometimes
are uncomfortable with um but if you
think like what's the node that your
answer should be targeting um what are
the paths from that to the effect and
that's what we showed people um but I
think an interesting IDE is about how
you abstract the model right and I think
that's sort of what you're getting at is
like how do you collapse some of these
paths into other uh other processes or
things like that um here I yeah there we
just didn't have the ability to do that
for this um I think that's a future sort
of future topic of how would you create
those um automatically I think that's
challenging um but if you have them in
some in particular domains it would be
interesting to test
them sure
your conclusions seem to
uh Jive very closely with
the with the conclusions of fast and
Frugal heuristics research program of
good G grenzer and his research group at
Max plant Berlin uh is that a reasonable
interpretation yeah it's it's not
inconsistent with that um and it's also
similar to I think what we find with the
people with uh more education and more
knowledge right it's like when you ask
the you know German uh students about
capitals in the US they you know pick
the cities they've heard of right um
whereas we ask American students that're
like overthinking and thinking like oh I
don't know maybe it's a trick question
it's not you know I can't think of any
capitals now but San Antonio or whatever
I don't know what the capital of Texas
is um but anyway it's similar to to that
when we have people with background
knowledge and people with that we've
done other studies where people have
varying degrees of back background
knowledge and you see people without
take the diagrams much more at face
value thank you fascinating I took so
many notes of things that that relate to
what I'll be talking tomorrow I have a
very concrete question that I hope will
be easy to address and a second one that
I just want to engage your thoughts the
first one is did you say that blood
pressure data RMS in the digital records
because as a patient if there's one
thing that I would imagine should would
be hard to keep track is it's not that
it's hard to keep track of it it's hard
to keep track of most things um I mean
so if you want to talk about a real mess
uh we didn't use race and ethnicity
because the data on that is too messy
it's not stored in a standardized way
and also because of copy and paste
errors you find errors in the same
record where race is changing over time
and you think I I don't know what the
correct value is the blood pressure
wasn't that uh it wasn't that we
couldn't extract the data we could um
it's that if you like think what happens
when you go to your primary care doctor
and they check your blood pressure
there's time pressure you're stressed
out right it's it's just a very noisy
measurement um and so it's measurement
itself is problematic not the not the
storage that was uh a lot of other other
variables and the other one the really
we were discussing before that in your
field discipline different from mine
different from mine you have to make
decisions or at least you're informing
people who make decisions and towards
the end you were referring to how we
don't really have power analysis tools
for caal inference but what I notice if
I follow you well that for very very
different effect sizes that you were
reporting in the percentage of responses
to the questioners or the the test you
did you are relying on statistical
significance but it seemed to me if I
followed it well that would there pretty
very very clear sample size issue there
because very very small effect sizes for
the percentage of respondents were
deemed significant therefore maying form
a decision and towards the end some of
those much bigger I'm talking 10 15%
different in response rate were
considered not significant I wonder how
how you're connecting this kind of if
going to r on statistical INF we may end
up with
making unwarranted recommendations on on
what to do so well there are two parts
so for the psychology studies and
decision-making we can do power analysis
and we have some idea of the effect size
and how much it's when I'm trying to
learn a causal model from data and the
model might be complicated and there's
relationships over time as all these
have um there's no way to figure out how
many how many observations do you need I
don't know it probably depends on the
complexity of the structure I don't know
um we don't we often don't even know
what's the right level of time
granularity um what's the right sampling
rate how often how fast are things
changing so we know how to measure them
um I couldn't tell you you know how many
observations do I need of you know if I
have 10 variables or 50 variables um you
know with certain density or whatever in
the CAA model I can't tell you how many
observations I need to be confident in
the CAA model whereas like for the
psychology studies we can we can do that
obviously and do par analysis there it
was that was for the point was for a
different different part one final
question before so two questions so one
is uh do you consider a possibility when
you do your research that the real cause
is not on the
list uh even more so it's not known I
mean in the history of medic there are
plenty examples of this uh and the
second one I was wondering if you ever
try to convince a teenager say to take
vitamins because they prevent you know
respiratory
disease uh or I mean when I was buying a
house the building inspector told me
that people buy the house and this way
and he was very experienced they look at
it they like it or not and then in
retrospect they explain
why uh because I think you know the
psychology part of this would explain
why you know playing with aliens is
perfectly explainable and modelable uh
but making decisions is very different
the more they are uh life uh you know
threatening uh the more it is sorry I
forgot the first part now uh yeah
because you yeah the first part the most
interesting and most uh you know
practical medicine is say you know
peptic
it was considered to be psychosomatic
disease and you can imagine how many
models you can make on that but it
turned out to be a bacterial infection
but bacteria were not on the list no
it's a huge problem and I mean in these
cases I can't do anything about it right
in the hospital data I can't change
what's measured I've have some studies
where I can and I've collected data
during pregnancy looking at stress
nutrition um I'm sure there are gaps and
then we also have things that we know
are probably causal but are too
expensive to measure and we can't
measure them but I mean is a possibility
to see that the list that you consider
is incomplete is by itself would be a
big finding say these variables do not
explain
um yeah sure um and there are methods
that purport to find uh unmeasured
variables though none have worked well
in the test that I've had um I don't I
don't I we can't confidently do that I
don't think personally um and then on
the second part uh I haven't convinced
teenagers of anything but I did convince
a student in my class and his father to
quit smoking uh because I use so many
causal examples about smoking and so uh
that's my my one success story of being
able to convince people to make a
decision from a caal
model thank you so much again
[Applause]
Samantha